yeah hello and welcome
night lifestream I hope you all had a
good start into the new week and ready
to start or join me in the new live
stream here Monday night so welcome to
all of you in the chat I'm going to what
am I going to do actually it did not
have a plan you know we have a couple of
tournaments going on I think that would
be one thing off just play just play em
play viewers yeah what do you what do
you think kick off with the tournament
then some viewer games maybe I don't
know the other thing that I could do I
could actually try to crank up my blitz
rating a little bit it's really not that
great yeah so maybe maybe do a quick
hourly super blitz something like that
and I also want to practice this a
little bit this is also an announcement
that I can make right away at this point
I'm going to why we're not paired I'm
going to play the yearly super blitz
tomorrow and this is going to be a
really really long tournament yeah I'm
switching back quickly to show you I
know I get the game the plague is should
go to 77 okay
the a.m.
oh thanks for subscribing feel ecat
feeling it yes that's the right name so
he again should cooler we have a
symmetrical group out in Quetta
Greenfeld
yeah tomorrow I'm going to play the
yearly super blitz this is a five-hour
tournament and my intention is to play
the full five hours which is long yeah
but what whatever it's necessary I will
try to do in this tournament I'm
starting it it starts at 6:00 p.m.
Central European Time and yeah it's some
five hours
okay I hope you'll join me that will be
a fun event so what's going on here I
don't mind so much if he takes this
fairly good control him I would need to
get in before that would be would be
really good to do but it's tough to go
before him Queen to b6 the king go
before so I probably should do this so
that at some point I can go a three
Knight takes d5 is not possible it's not
technically technically feasible I
wonder if I should actually go look a
one simply to to force before probably
have to play this also hmm yeah I always
have problems here with shook hood I
know him from from my chest 24 streams
always filled severely underrated to me
maybe you can see five as possible
because f5 okay
maybe this is an idea it should force a
clean trade almost removes the Queen
I've got night to see if I have so I
expect him to take yeah okay welcome to
Bavarian Swiss from Zurich and also good
evening to Malta a five coming
yeah next Sunday
oh thank you for the donation bad
bishops that's great thank you a lot
yeah we're playing in the in the in the
German league
we're playing the currently leaders from
boham a place fantastic against me all
the time c5 what a move yeah and no I'm
pretty I'm pretty okay with this match
against whom I think they are the
leaders in this in this league but teams
are fairly fairly evenly matched
so I don't expect us I don't think we
had them we really underdogs them I
think it's a fairly even match yeah I
could I could face a grandmaster or
close to it yeah one possible opponents
me hearts I'd say he's a very strong I
am
kingi Sanders a self-made
position is a draw maybe no yep very
well played
yeah I'm taking fewer challenges but I'm
going to play the viewers after the
tournament I'm going to play this
tournament and then we'll see I have to
double click the draw of a I always
forget that
what is the prince variation the
Sicilian I've never heard about that
I simply need information there what the
prince variation is yeah unfortunately I
need to double click this the draw
button but this is not really I'm not
really am having this this is not really
part of my mo where I have don't have
this remember that I have to do this ok
there was so any other question that is
the prince variation yeah ah ok f3 is
the prince variation f3 is an
interesting law yes this is what what
Magnus played in the final the final
game of the World Championship match and
it's it's a fairly it's a fairly solid
line actually I'm sacrificing a pawn to
get this
better we going it doesn't have a direct
direct that it's possible or come on you
have to be kidding me
I had silly
that's very silly when I did him I mean
I could have just played normally and be
better and I wanted to do it nicely and
he has this queen III response
I was already nicely positioned with the
bishop pair for nothing but then you
want to play fancy chess as I always say
keep it simple and then I don't do it
I'm not sure f5 is a good idea it's an
interesting idea because white tries to
activate the bishop and that is
generally speaking a good idea but it
also weakens f5 my bishops are still
we're just really strong Bishop f4 at
Citi won't take a four that doesn't work
and who p8 is a natural way to improve
okay goes back hmm he wants to play
Bishop g3 I guess that's very reasonable
idea oh I don't want to trade him now I
did watch the cars match I had had a
lesson I I know I know what happened I
know that somehow Magnus lost on time
while having while having rook and
Bishop against rook it was a very it's a
very weird thing to happen yeah hmm yeah
I don't like to take this could be a
problem
I think f3 is this a three-line is
perfectly fine and this is saying that I
did not know that it's called the prince
variation I've never heard about that
I only am in you a prince variation in
the in the groom felt okay now I could
take with this Bishop actually but it is
ourself pen hmm
hmm okay that's very helpful okay I'm a
bit behind and losing the first game
trying is the first step to failure
yeah yeah that's probably true
okay the Owen defense okay
96 looks a bit odd no it looks very odd
yeah I could kick it around even further
yeah that's develop
huh like this if he takes I have this
this is a pretty nice intermediate check
winning between yeah sometimes sometimes
it is really the case yeah some of the
younger players they don't even know how
it is to play with our increment or
delay and I've ever seen weird things
happen if they actually have to play one
of those ancient time controls when you
really think I sound like Vienna hats
okay I don't think so hat so gives a
Bavarian yet and he sounds a bit like
Bavarian I am NOT okay so I'm going to
sacrifice that you changed them and try
to break through opponent is really not
believing on resigning
yeah let's get Windows 7
okay it's a checkmate probably a next
month will be enough as he falls
explosive if you had that King not c4
exploded at the onion okay what are we
going to do here yeah I don't I want
that fire going on an inverter what what
kind of plays that my thirty something
that's not good
yeah I play the yelling super blitz
tomorrow five hours seems like really
long event but why can't you do yes I
will stream the full five hours I'm
playing my pet liner in the children I
know it's not good but it's just like
it's a bad habit my score is still
excellent somehow with this crap it's
not good yeah I know
yeah yeah I will probably do the
alternate break yes and and also I will
definitely need new tea during this kind
of stream okay seems like he's tried
form forward check medium on h4 h5 I
don't think this is going to work all
that easily
okay let's activate
let's activate stuff can i play on the
earth file wow it's not going to be all
that all that easy
yeah damn right there's no attack that's
true but I also don't have an attack
I've got nothing
great in particular
[Music]
Queen f6 king of seven I don't think
it's so dangerous
ah thanks for the cheer circuit
McNuggets
Ruka p7 I can go look a seven or c7 yeah
if I'm not I don't think I'm getting a
checkmate did she end if I'm not I'm
kind of okay I have them strong c3 pawn
you know this this looks very very
direct let's aim okay chick he steps
onto the H follicle ooh cage area that
should win and what's going on yeah I
have Bishop b5
huh see she's not explained yeah it's a
that's a good one just unexplained or
mysterious chest
okay so just said g6 is hanging him well
it's not not really
I don't really have something cool here
or I can do I can't play Bishop b5 check
again but that it doesn't do much she
can maybe just sacrifice pretty awkward
okay I need to make a move and I'm down
to 20 seconds this is not really a great
[Music]
I'm not happy with this but I'm
threatening rook h8 here possibly
winning the Queen almost okay Jade is a
funny movie next like 92 okay Jade and
then then I'm meeting him okay not great
Queen age 7 I might drop back we'll have
19 seconds yeah I know the two thirds
but what can you do now yet the check
there on b7
ah
I always expect him to check me it
doesn't happen I know he does
I know sometime yeah it's crazy that's
crazy what the heck what a taro tenement
is that that's crazy what I'm doing here
I want sixty Hort
that's funny you have some 1,800 guys
being on third place crazy okay
and what are you what are you doing here
come on I really have to win quickly now
everything else is not enough come on
Leigh
yeah I try to be as quick as possible
and go on just resign and we get to the
new game no they're the two or thirds
right that's that's the one I have to
say probably you will play f1 made me
okay okay I have to berserk the rest I
guess yeah it's time for strong measures
let's go g5 boom
and don't drop dead no probably not
Oh blunder g4 it's really it that sets
small fish yeah it really it's not a
good position and it's really what what
it is at the end oh I want to trade
stuff now what I'm doing is I want to
win this game really quickly it's a bit
crazy I know
[Music]
and not really my kind of chess but no
it's not the tea I don't have any team
okay Boozer can play the Latvian gambit
okay anyway I take C - okay
yeah 95 Eve okay now we cannot play not
play Queen age 5 where's the Queen going
to be 3 probably Quincy 5 got D 3 then
it's it's a very funny position Queen B
3 now I see actually @xg ATM so I have
to have two
yourself it's nots not such a it's not
so terrible in the context of blitz game
and what were probably immensely
irritated by this this weird stuff okay
is he taking the look come on what else
is there what is why doing him it's not
taking the rook okay
this is the idea now possible yeah what
we'll probably flag that's true
fun with flags I've got flex ok so check
ok Kim Ji Won do actually smash on g3 or
I can just take b3 of course a d3 but
the rook is actually hanging ok
that's funny I said really the point
down that you wanted to take here
hmm maybe it is okay this is not what I
wanted but he's got 20 seconds on the
clock
93 made Kadapa
he's got no check on his hands should
have played that right away that was
silly playing a 5 the stumbled right
into mate and played this like a friggin
idiot what am I doing here
okay look I can take no check okay
that was really bad 94 was me I had a
mate really sure okay
I didn't see it I know I didn't see it I
really didn't
okay anyway Kings gambit please yeah I'm
I'm happy I'm happy to to play the Kings
gambit next move next game first of all
I can prepare for I really did
actually not that terrible
well this is this is a position I'm
quite quite happy with I wonder if he
actually just castles along now know
that ever put the Queen on th forum
short castle would be pretty risky
oh come on I have to take it right I
don't really see black moving the night
where would you move it yeah anyway I
have to fire here anyway
fire okay don't you have to take that oh
wow that's cool I didn't see that coming
at all
like the Queen was able to take it okay
and then I'm threatening this 97 on the
COTS I can almost take it I can almost
take it take thinking wait what did I do
this
you should be six Andrew gave one year
if he survived that one he has to really
find some good stuff Bishop f6 maybe
maybe Bishop f6 still holds it looks
sick but should we have six that's the
same idea that's the same idea but this
now and then look f1 check he defended
this stuff I don't believe it
unbelievable night F for coming I really
thought that what would would would kill
black crazy we came
I cannot take unfortunately
yeah sure and finds all the only motion
sick at least he needs a bit of time
this should be seven now of course he
find him
of course he finds it this is the only
possibility wait he blundered the Queen
hmm that didn't go too well from like
hmm okay anyway our 12th place Bishop d6
yeah maybe we should be successor bishop
see sorry King g7 Minnie just a fencer I
just yeah what has just happened hmm
yeah nothing too great for black yeah I
don't go go I don't care see em my back
okay so we're essentially playing a
bullet game I'm just going to develop
quickly and see what happens I can take
this
if I'm counting correctly I'm a pizza
with all this nonsense
I was really weird
that was weird come on give me the
points oh how I see first places they
have crazy crazy points impossible to
catch him don't blunder one all games
yeah I have to do something crazy to
catch up after that that crap star the
only way to do it
come on okay let me okay man
Wow okay mark India to new Vani I don't
think he's going to play no okay
so hey maybe second place or something
you mean am I going to be five really
are you serious
yeah you don't see you candidate master
you don't see that often in fact it's
not not surprised to have the variance
with what is this this is a really weird
form of gambit by Caspar clown again I'm
going to go from a direct attack very
direct attack
so I'm and thread need to take Queen age
five smash on g7 stuff like that it's
actually close close to working I've
used 15 15 seconds when I can actually
do this this is quite important even the
bishop on c4
yeah I think I'm winning mf6 next
I have six next we'll kill him I think
give me give me give me him sixes is end
of game yeah right there could be tons
of candidate masters but it's not a
title that is claimed that often you
still have to pay for it
I don't know what it is probably
something around 100 euros and it's not
super prestigious so it's not not taken
right that many players
can almost people finish five okay third
place
maybe I'm getting at this - EMG yes okay
come on
all over chance she got $800 last night
well what did happen that sounds great
that's really a lot I mean I'm happy
with even lower donations she got 800
okay hmm
[Music]
what's going on you have a really weird
night yeah but he's opened up the age
file for me actually this is noise 95
mm-hmm no I came well I'm working so
there is some you have to be a bit
relaxed in terms of move quality at
times you cannot play perfectly and I'm
going to take and over to see form I'm
still better the question is if I can
manage this timewise taking is probably
not a great idea this may be I'm not
sure about it the night only five now
looks very strong but I've got to be
found not good yeah I shouldn't have
done that the knight on d5 is too strong
and I only have thirty seconds so he
will probably get away with this stuff
and 96 wasn't actually that great I
think and the position is actually very
good for me I think I'm just winning
actually the question is do I manage
this timewise maybe I do
that's a great night on a date oh my
goodness okay how much do you have spent
on my hair each month um I can tell you
I take like one or two razor blades and
you and I need this the screamer
for what shaving some splits caps what
are you going to do
okay I don't know the theory of the
slide that's a bit tricky if he takes on
c6 now I usually I usually play d6 there
if I if I'm if I'm there yeah the hair
jokes are funny yes at one point I
decided to not bother and simply get rid
of them yeah does it doesn't feel like
I've got enough there
thanks for the Chia now that was this
bad it's just a bad position
yeah that's it's really crap him what a
crap game really really not great him
takes with the pawn that's really ugly
but the position is so bad it probably
doesn't matter you only get the sound
now what does that mean no like no no no
what I'm saying the only opportunity
here is and it was crap god damn it how
stupid can you be him haha come on it
was really terrible still second place
for some real
okay call me wrong no never had a beard
don't intend to get one nothing wrong
with it just never okay with a quick one
yeah okay don't blunder it's kind of
untouchable he won all the games but I
get second place somehow yeah somehow
okay well some any some funny games are
thinking this one and not happy with
this smooth water and okay it's it's not
a vacation
okay I think I should prevent this and
prevent the upon push and yeah okay is
it better to shave before or after the
shower okay I don't know what this is
too much information but I actually
shave under the shower
okay I'm just a pawn up yeah for
absolutely zilch nothing to say besides
I'm a poor knob and it's got a wacky
rook probably a six is going to be
played I wonder him this is actually
okay keeping everything covered and look
at the one d7 and the C pawn okay let's
so cants do this
and c6 will win I think should be
touchdown for the c-pawn hmm actually
isn't touchdown for the Seaport
[Music]
shoot like I screwed it up at least in
terms of winning quickly as Crudup
yeah I know I will be point promotes
okay so actually a second clear second
but not more one against the sky and hey
it's a bullet game you know and he
didn't he didn't seem to do all that
well with those crazy positions so let's
be completely crazy and this is in fact
really really weird again it's it's
basically bullet chess have seven that
he played well that he played well
probably have very no humor those people
no humor just playing super boring him
no I'm going to play viewers after the
Chairman okay and to blunder stuff I'm
catching up hmm oh it's probably still
almost impossible to completely screw it
up
what does he have to do to to screw it
up it's really tougher how to imagine
[Music]
threatening whoopty 5 which is very
simple to spot but still ok hmm I don't
have many squeeze it is pretty bad yeah
just e5 is going to win yeah it's it's
it's too easy I don't know even plays
Premal stalemate
what are you doing here buddy
okay you found the mate
okay thank you so I'm going to get
second place and this in this tournament
with some extremely crazy games but yeah
it was fun to fun to get there after
being on forty-something at the very
beginning okay
I came on it just it's just fun how
those tournaments of course I can play
super solid and score better but it was
in the tradition of the three-minute
madness videos I guess at the end okay
so um let's get going and play some
viewers um yeah let's do blitz time
controls yeah that would be good and I'm
going to start here we soak him let's
get going
no first first place played perfectly
let's go for the enolate counter gambit
yeah that's a really funny gambit
I don't think this is that bad actually
as weird as it looks but I don't think
it has a clear refutation the thing is
some what it's often actually
recommended as the antidote
of course
f4 is really really really ambitious but
there are 95 maybe
mmm-hmm you know the idea forces to to
grab more space yeah I should be seven I
think you probably will take on e7 now
and then I'm getting rid of this hey
this bishop is not so bad but I can't we
will have trades okay it's an easy
development
there there's some truth to that
Otzi complex the saying yeah the point
here is I have h5g form and this
majority is really am
white does not have a clear counter play
against that
I don't really see what white is doing
the bishop on it was not too active no
that should be better for for black
quite substantially ya know to move 11
what I need to do is actually what I
need to do is the subscribers they only
have those standard stars as a symbols I
want to want something that is more
fitting for this channel but I don't I
don't yet know what it should be maybe
you have some some suggestions and I'm
not really the super creative okay and
this is going to be very tricky he
cannot take se to Hanks and I'm
threatening f.2nd twangs and everything
Hanks I don't know that looks bad it
looks pretty bad
well so I live in York yeah so drunken
lawyer squat quite well and there were
some in those blitz games it's just like
it's just about having a good position
yeah that is it's nice yeah but you have
to win the games and especially in blitz
it's really important to be technically
alert and grab the chances if it's just
about having good positions yeah I mean
my blitz rating would be probably 2600
and not just to five like it is in
feeder blitz has brought so many good
positions because I look something off
have silly time management but it's all
part of the overall strength okay wait I
shouldn't I should pay attention there's
actually a counter threat I want the
droopy one for Luke a one mate but he
had a threatens his own
how do I made here I don't see it
actually
[Music]
not so happy with how I'm playing this
but I will probably win on time I'm up
there are minutes actually minutes yeah
thanks for the game Sookie so okay let's
go play the drunken lawyer okay bye-bye
two Bavarian Swiss I know what you have
to be up early
keep the Swiss GNP running oh I didn't
see the draw fire I'm sorry Sookie
apologizes for a draw offer that I did
not see actually okay first he says that
he scored a good win in the board game
with my English repertoire this is
actually funny as a student of mine
recently showed me that if you play like
this you can actually threaten to take
here yeah and 95-96 wins the queen but
woody five that now was thwarted by the
lawyer I should have taken on if I'd
actually I forgot to do that now he's
gonna form man oh it's good before okay
I should focus I should have taken only
five so that after efore I had 94 which
I don't have now and 95 he's got d5 so I
actually have to go back which is not
really ideal the only good thing is that
this position is still extremely solid
[Music]
good move
yeah Black is fine and I passed route
through sorry I screwed up the opening
yeah maybe
let's let's take this but I mean he can
go to the three but it's probably not
the end of the world with I got to d4
square
stopping a forum I wonder if he should
take on b3 at some point yeah if I go
Bishop c2 and get this out of the range
of this night maybe you should grab the
bishop am
this is a position where if black
doesn't get something going in the next
couple of moves I will probably be quite
okay so I go back and have before now on
the agenda I have very little experience
with playing on chess calm it's
currently discussed that sounds great
I've may evolve austere your results in
in the league games after one lesson
with me but it's probably not it got you
to the lesson okay so I put an item to
be five after you went a five and we can
just make sense
ninety-six that's a good move
it's a good move I guess okay good to
see ya thanks for the photo was your
time I am on the way to deform I don't I
don't really think there is something
like rating inflation on on on chess
servers that much it's just about
different different start different
starting starting rating so you simply
start differently and all of the servers
and this makes them ratings not really
comparable there's nothing bad about
that for example my rating in blitz is
2300 and there are people there with
2600 whenever I'm very certain I'm
actually better than them but somehow
don't get this rating up probably
playing the wrong tournaments or playing
I don't know what what I'm doing there
but I'm not improving it somehow
ah I come on really I didn't pay any
attention of course yeah and I'm getting
mated now I didn't look anymore I didn't
look anymore
[Music]
yeah Queen c7 friends made I mean the
position is strategic name so close to
winning but it kind of fits um alright
if you say you win from lost positions
okay I really didn't look anymore which
is obviously not a good idea I didn't
really I didn't I didn't didn't check it
I was just thinking you were checking a
c3 and I didn't pay attention that there
was a main threat
okay so actor oh I have to I have to
checkmate now and this is why my rating
is not going up you have probably it's a
it's too much talk yeah I should do this
kind of stream ever you just like sit
down yeah just just like feverishly try
to win some games
yeah this is a dangerous setup
we're playing 3 plus 2 and I 1 3 minutes
or 5 this is a line where I'm I'm black
has fairly easy plane
yeah boss thanks for the game TDL so
take this and yeah no I'm going for
winning with more time on the clock that
has started with I've had this before in
this line
Ruki one maybe stuff whim or or f3 which
is ugly ugly ugly but maybe necessary
almost has to play a three I don't
really see what else otherwise I jump
into f3
it's almost mandatory otherwise and you
should play at some point it's going to
really take that's made that's going to
be made
Arturo Ruka h2 made or rook edge one
meter
that's made it's unavoidable Bishop
takes Bishop takes this really made
mixing it made make smooth
yeah thanks for the game actor oh yeah
it simply shouldn't cancel just here
don't cancel wait wait until Black has
somehow committed and I play B 3 a 3
something like that not canceling it's
really dangerous
ok so Joseph Joseph ok let's go for some
g6 action modern defense yeah in this
variation don't cancel is really a good
good advice because this h5 business is
extremely dangerous
ok so I tried a modern defense an
opening that I actually have played in
tournaments s when I was young and
didn't know better now it's not so bad
to play the model but it's a tricky
opening I really think it's tricky for
both sides as we see in this game
threatening one c3 oh wow really
I can't win material now in more than
one way
yeah if she says I should have my own
teaching show we have in fact I want to
do something like that yeah do something
like that actually plan to do it simply
on HS what I have not yet done is
determined when I'm going to do it and
so on and current they have some some
projects that require attention the
completion of the e4 repertoire for
example I have to make videos for that
for example it's lots of work that's
going to be a made smothered mate you
know nice one
thanks for the game Joseph no we're not
atomic please but I currently I
currently cannot I need to finish some
stuff first yeah and then then I do
something else
oops I'm not really good at multitasking
I have to finish one thing and then send
start the other and I also don't quite
know this is this potential teaching
show when to schedule and this is also a
little bit of an issue because my
schedule is rather full please please
don't a back for game in the chat I
really don't don't like that I just go
from from top to bottom and you're
actually not that far away from the from
the from the top of the list 3 a.m.
German time would be good for us
hey yeah I know it's a bit tricky I
already feel
[Music]
yeah those shows are already quite late
and I have to watch out a little bit for
my sleeping patterns okay so what's
going on here I'm two pawns up
why not Bishop e7 did that did that win
stuff or something if it didn't win
stuff I don't want to take the night
see some maybe had a better move well
I'm quite happy with the bishop and two
extra pawns threatening made okay maybe
green Red Hulk is following what the
heck is a green Red Hulk
now Bishop c5 I tried to dominate this
night and it probably will work black
cannot Castle maybe that are the cue
rules yeah I'm just going from top to
bottom means the earliest challenge
first
green red flick it's just a name okay
what Portugal what does what do they
have yeah they have read and and green
right but not more red green what other
colors do they have I currently don't
have it on the radar they have more than
red and green right Portugal red green
black right
and the yellow mmm that sounds like a
pretty colorful flag I was wondering
what kind of political configuration air
that that would be a would be a funny
coalition in Germany my internet
connection issues are not solved I just
have I mean actually already had
problems earlier me I have a Mac with
Flex you're completely right way is
Portugal check check check
wait
so where's Portugal give me Portugal he
is Portugal yeah it's mostly green and
red yam and something complicated in the
middle okay so thanks for the game Fritz
grant let's play the wayward son any
over the blood tournaments coming this
year um I haven't learned that much I
will play a small tournament that I've
already played last year in Bavaria in
water book nice week and tournament that
is going to be early September I think
September 9th September 10th something
like that that I will definitely play I
already confirmed my participation and
yeah this is the only thing that I have
planned for sure
and very likely of course I will play
the the local town championship of my my
own chess club let's say that will be in
early June yeah I could work out that I
meet Fiona in Berlin that's possible she
said that she will arrive on the 20th
and I'm still there on the 20th so maybe
we can yeah say hello I don't know
exactly what she will do yeah you should
go to Berlin it's going to be a really
really cool tournament I think so I've
won a pawn that's good but White has the
bishop pair and a wide open position so
let's see him this looks like a decent
choice cover important squares yeah so
that the pawn is actually useful okay I
think I'm going back six looks like it
would square I don't know I don't want
to take let's not take if I can get one
half of the bishop pair that should help
and I'll take
I was very generous ok thanks for the
game wayward son
this is Sam by the way this opening this
opening them I don't know exactly what
is the name of that you said to Goering
gambit I think it is I really don't
recommend that at all
I mean this is a system with Bishop g4
and Bishop before it's super comfortable
for black you can maybe if you prepare
it very well by the word you can try to
yeah almost you can play for a draw
let's say but you very rarely will get
interesting attacking chances if black
declines the gambit ok let's play know
what kill boat and we get scotch four
nights huh he has taken this very very
early this night and one day if he five
is involved in this portion let's try it
is interesting yeah I thought Queen -
Queen is seven
the Queenie seven was more [ __ ] problem
he it looks very comfortable after
castles I've got Bishop h6 winning an
exchange and g6 Bishop g5 is even worse
oh maybe the six maybe the six is still
possible to not lose everything now yes
to play d6 okay I am probably still d6
but then Queen f3 and I win I win rook
at least
yeah that's a double attack
yeah that's pretty costly did anybody of
you probably some of you did watch the
Carleton Nakamura official random match
some of it yeah thanks for the game Lord
Kinbote I did not watch anything I made
me watch like 30 minutes or so yeah when
I had dinner on Saturday and that was
the only thing I saw did they have any
interesting games I sometimes feel that
Fisher random yeah leads to boring games
yeah so I switched it up a little bit
and play down a deform opening Queen's
Gambit and let's see what happens here
is three plus two so I can relax a
little bit
yeah I saw they have installed those
heart monitors yeah always checking the
pulse it's interesting yeah it's
interesting too to what I watched a bit
when doing a fairly complicated and
critical looking position
I watched them that Magnus still had a
really yeah it was completely unfazed by
a Jeff so here I try to play this
that make b7 or I try to play in a way
that that the b7 bishop looks bad
yeah okay cousin some average heart rate
was lower yeah it's probably in really
because he's doing more sports I think
he Carroll also looks physically fit as
well but probably not to the same degree
as scarless if I take here and take on
c6 isn't that good we should be good
right
and they had to take it
oh okay I don't win material here right
I don't see it at least maybe be five
maybe be five so that I can get rid of
one of the bishops at least Bishop e7
looks like the only booth otherwise I'm
winning more material I think Oh queen
da de McQueen has no squares huh
okay okie dokie so hmm
let's keep that not easy not easy at all
near Group C for there is if five I
guess
hmm not too good yeah actually black is
quite active
I don't have a good good good
continuation here
I was basically losing this no matter
what
now I did not finish Younce series
against HR on chess 24i I only had a
brief look because I mean I was very too
busy studying my my own stuff do you
think mama Darrell can beat cards oh it
was silly here look a seven oh my
goodness what am I doing here
ah crazy I'm playing crazy what what the
heck I really should pay some attention
here Wow
yeah it's easy I'm coming from an okay
position to an equal position to or to a
lost position if it just lost them
completely lost
completely lost
yeah and it was pretty unnecessary hmm I
wonder I was led great I've got the bump
on
near looks like I only need the flag
Wow
it was really really bad yeah thanks for
the game
I am paunescu so the witch let's go play
the witch
okay okay I can go back to Queen f6
dangerous pre-move actually right you're
right
there was a dangerous free move
yeah unfortunately that didn't didn't
get punished or didn't got didn't get
didn't get punished
yeah that's a question what do I think
about Arbutus yeah as usual I think it's
it's its mixture it's mixed I've seen
terrible ones good ones I'm actually
inhabited myself yeah not not a very
high ranked one but I would be actually
be qualified to to beat the arbiter in a
third league match in Germany so I could
be the arbiter in one of the matches
that I usually compete in I got this
license last year the main point of it
was to simply know the rules better I'm
not really planning to to to do many
arbiter jobs the Queen to d7 is
something that black definitely could
try try to win their porn 25
now there is no minimum rating to be an
arbiter and oath and so on sometimes I
feel this is an issue yes once in a
while it would help if they could
actually play chairs and in a way by the
way this is not such an important issue
the whole arbiter business if you have
an increment time control because then
lots of issues are simply resolved
automatically most of the time the
arbiter was some was necessary or is
necessary to settle time scramble issues
and if you have an increment usually you
don't have those situations where one
side tries to win on time yeah bye-bye
you're hitting the clock and whatnot
yeah and this just doesn't happen that
much anymore when you have incremental
control and an additional thing that is
also not happening anymore is that the
arbiter actually fatigue cannot
recapture that the album with the old
would set in a non increment template or
the arbiter sometimes simply had to
decide on the result of the game
basically yes so you could basically say
okay I claim a draw and then the arbiter
had to judge had to judge if this is a
draw or not and in many cases they were
simply not qualified to do so and with
increment this is not the case anymore
they don't need that because you do
claim draws you simply play the game out
which is for me a huge point where I
like to have
increments there any problem there what
the heck are you writing there yeah it's
a bit of spam in the chat unless maybe I
don't understand it yeah that's true
with the with the current route said
with official time control it's not
really that necessary that the arbiter
has a high playing strength but it was
it was performed and often times that
wasn't was an issue thanks for
subscribing Agustin
so how do I get get something going here
not that easy can you please stop
writing this this letters I mean that
really helpful
yeah so I just am yeah
we need to moderate now okay that did
happen I was close to doing it myself
so here the wedge has actually offended
this quite well
[Music]
[Music]
well defended
minkos us how much time you take
approximately to finish a book you mean
like reading it or after or writing it
writing is tough the same my my name is
owen between ian book took ages a couple
of years actually the e4 repertoire is
going to be released on chasuble is I
took a 8 month something like that 8 to
9 months
no I did not consider to write an on
opening book
I think the one one point why I didn't
do it is simply it's not so easy to add
something new let's say in a middle game
book
what exactly is there what you can can
do what has fresh input it's difficult I
think it's possible but it's I don't
really feel like I have a point that I
want to definitely have any book yeah
thanks for playing the wench
so Minko 36 Plus no one of this is maybe
five
okay I'm going before I feel with an
attack on the queenside yes cancelled
long really really early let's see
how to do this I think I go here browse
the web says can you sell more books on
chesil than regular print I wouldn't say
you can necessarily sell more in terms
of copies but it's a bit easier actually
to write if you go for a chasuble format
because you have to yeah some things
that you need to do for print book you
don't have to do like you have to set
you have to determine where to put the
diagrams and things like that
yeah so f6 is possible then ever
definitely yeah we need to set a piece
done I don't think I should just play
GTX but I have some kind of player on
the queenside
so I can take you and I takes pawn takes
Bishop takes Queen d6 is the thing
after the Queen takes on d6 I don't I
don't have a great move that's the
problem I can take on b3 now but if I
take on b3 d 7 just doesn't work
[Music]
maybe we have to do this it looks really
ugly but the other stuff doesn't seem to
work I did not like to allow him this
check like group g1 but yeah there's a
discussion right now in the twitch chat
about different time controls in in
different leagues yeah I agree
it's kind of a pest yeah it's all it's
all different and if you actually well
that doesn't apply to to that many
players but if you actually play in
other countries then it gets completely
confusing I mean I play in the German
league and sometimes in the Dutch league
sometimes in the Belgium league and they
have all different time controls and I
can tell you that in absolutely every
team match the first thing I do is ask
the arbiter what the time control is
it's a bit ridiculous but I have to do
it and
[Music]
yeah this is a complete mess
yeah this is a typical argument yeah
that poor small chest clubs only have
old clocks that can't have increment
yeah I'm going to be brutal then say
then then close the frigging club if you
cannot afford that you should simply
shut it down yeah okay
so Bishop take seven eight not really if
you cannot afford to some some free
inches clocks what's the point it's
really really not the point we would
what this is just not a huge investment
and you cannot play yeah like Stone Age
chess the whole time it's not possible
okay okay I got to check here which is
an important resource I think and in
fact after King c2 we're looking to mate
and this I have a really funny variation
now here
it's completely bonkers
that's a funny Lynam Queen takes h6
Bishop b2 check and then Bishop g7
discover check
I have a double check but it probably
doesn't help or desert
Bishop D for chick doesn't help
they each the problem is my position is
still not good it was just a funny trick
I was still not in good shape 95 I got
checkmated
I can't have to do this
yeah this is the thing are they they
think if you are in a chess club yeah
you you can do it that you can actually
run it yeah with no cost like the member
fees should be low yeah I should never
invest anything
bla bla bla and I mean this is crazy
why not yeah raise the member fee and do
something what happened
hey moving on time I just I was just a
bit surprised
I mean b2 would probably win here yeah
it was a completely crazy gaming coach
have no clue what was going on
it gave thanks for playing yeah
sometimes and sometimes here and what
those clubs charge and then they tell me
how we charge like 4 euros a month or
something so what kind of what is that
like 4 or 5 euros what kind of a sum is
that if you are in any sort of sports
club and whatever it is it's it's a lot
higher yeah chess chess people are weird
okay let the meat kick chess clock with
increment cost yeah hmm I'm not entirely
sure the prices have gone down
considerably it's really because it's a
standard adults play 35 euros a year new
cloth
well then raise the raise the fees yeah
how are you ever going to get anywhere
with this kind of with this kind of
membership theme
okay so this is a complicated position I
go for this and then 95
the funny thing is that in many cases
nobody needs a chess club and because
you can't play online yeah of course you
have to talk you think about this if you
have a range of members that cannot
afford that you can you can do lower
membership fees for them I played C form
here in order to get 95 and get some
activity going
folks here what city do you live in what
is 60% unemployed rate I cannot really
believe what what kind of city is that
okay 60 55 euros a year for adults so
feels pretty low
yes he's six this week I know
hmm okay sixty percent so it's crazy
home
yeah that's it gets crazy now take the
bishop
yeah I mean the the kind of monthly
membership rate that you take depends a
lot of course on the on the club if you
play in higher leagues for example and
you don't have sponsorship in some way
you simply cannot go for yeah what for
for like fifty yeah just doesn't work if
you take this if you um if you for
example play if you play in high leaks
the costs are not higher thanks for
playing let me eat kick kick sir Polly
yeah for example I can give you an
example if you play like in the third
League in Germany I like like our my
club just you have to pay the averages
for example the the our pitches will
cost probably the whole season will cost
roughly three to four hundred euros yeah
the whole the whole thing then then you
have to have to pay the the travelling
cost yeah and you have to mean traveling
course sounds a bit a bit funky I mean
you have to drive to the to the to the
to the matches and if you pay the
players actually and don't expect them
to to pay them to pay on their own then
it get costly it really gets costly so
there's simply no way to finance higher
leagues of you charge that lot of money
that was t6 yeah the arbiters aren't
that expensive
I know but it piles up you know it is
it's just one part of it of course but
it costs a couple of hundred euros to
play in in the third League
became a knight is attacked on deform
any tips on getting started when you're
new to chess it's a bit it's a very
general kind of question and it depends
a bit on on on you experience and what
kind of resources you have it's not a
bad idea to to focus at first on getting
some abilities and calculation
understand tactics but I mean I sure
agree the chest Arbutus are not really
expensive in the leagues it just said we
were just talking about the membership
fees and they are simply different if
you if you play higher leagues or the
calculation let's say it's different
oh that's fantastic thanks for the
donation no a sustainable membership fee
for chest up is in 200 euros per month
but but it is it I think it just should
be a reasonable amount and not something
that doesn't work I mean
I can tell you that that my club charges
twelve heroes a month for adults six
euros for four for junior players and we
have we charge less form we charge less
for let's say people that are unemployed
and so on
okay this is a tough game I'm a pawn up
but it's not not a super easy winner
think what I try to do is make the deep
horn count I cannot do it now yes during
a stream you cannot go back in a twitch
in a twitch video you have to wait until
the thing is completed so how do we win
now here maybe this
yeah rook to f6 this is going to be very
dangerous
look here it should lead to mate somehow
hmm which is almost made I know I don't
see it though it's pretty bad
I just tried Knight takes and then night
if for maid
yeah me it's something easier I still
think that will do the job though I'm
just quicker here he would make me next
Mickey Karras you have 94 mm-hmm maybe
thanks for the game yes playing fence
himself now and I'm going for an
eloquence poops and the cans was
declined
you're very solid very solid to set up a
white and it's also solid I'm going to
win this pawn
huh what to do here
I'd like to play against f2 somewhat
such I don't really have much firepower
try to develop like this
the event himself was taking a lot of
time after giving away the default pawn
yeah makes sense to feel kettle so how
am I going to make some headway luckily
one is coming with a 5 next it's a
slightly annoying issue
yeah I lost I lost one funny Colorado
game some days ago yeah so I've
centralized this is good but not don't
have a clear a clear plan when I found
really funny on chest when you for you
get those badges like yeah you you win
against the Grandmaster you get a badge
you win against and I am you get a badge
and so on and after playing on that
server forum for some years actually I
recently won the first game against the
W F M women fear master and I got the W
F M batch
he's five okay
yeah I think you're d5
can't pop med school back
are those long questions later volley I
think it's possible that he did not
calculate everything
[Music]
um just look good
it does not look great
[Music]
hmm yeah I have to I have to do this
return upon the voice I never get
getting my pieces out I was actually
planning rook takes Bishop takes rook d8
but he's got rook e1 hmm I only know
then Queen f3
[Music]
hmm okay if it doesn't work it doesn't
work okay
I think when comes Faro said he didn't
calculate there was a situation where
there was so many when he had some
additional pieces in the attack and
there were less defenders of course they
because part of calculates extremely
quickly and it just means that in some
cases he does not have to look super
deeply because he feels ok this this
will work and I can assure you if there
are very clear cases yeah I saw that
before but I didn't want to put the
knight onto a - no there if there are
extreme cases of having far more pieces
then in some cases you really don't need
to calculate all that deeply you just
say ok that will work and and if you
have a good intuition you will be right
down most of the time it also depends a
lot on the time situation if they had a
complicated late middle game you simply
had don't have time to calculate and
then he will probably rely on such a
general observation form then if he's in
a situation where he could actually
calculate it when he has the time to do
so
ok thanks for the game fence himself
just play 83 let's go just play
oh okay let's go other kinds again
g3 it's a rare line against a lakhan's
it's not so bad I mean okay it should
not lead to to something fantastic
I didn't pre-move 95 I dropped that was
a drop actually I did something I pre
moved some these six ones I think and
blundered P is very early on in the
other icons yeah but here I will add
Centauri resignation I mean it's not a
good position with that you can you can
try de Quinn d1 okay Ford Prefect right
from the Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy yeah a bullet for retired people
I once dead yeah the slow bullet one one
minute was was some increment yeah and
of course I can do a bullet tournament
once for for young people let's see
now I have not played against the chess
hustlers in New York City I've been to
New York but I did not did not do any
chance at all them it's an interesting
line going for a quick g5
I got you five coming let's go
it's not actually true the Dutch team
champion with wound of I think we won in
2012 if I'm not mistaken
[Music]
I'm touch sorry you need to you need to
repeat the question I don't see it
anymore the check is so long if you
repeat it and try to answer it
yeah g4 was hanging but I don't think it
was so important that it actually was
saying didn't you have to retake who's
there I'm just playing this in a very
aggressive style and see what Oh 95 95
g6 is also something I mean 95 must be
right yeah Mia please wait please
replace a repeater the question and
touch because I cannot scroll up the
whole chat okay so g 6g 6 a black cannot
cancel this 97 i hello - no joke chess
you're not locked on to the chess what
are you doing the key so I can play 97
maybe
I have not not looked at the Perth's
book
bye-bye marine yet not Authority yes we
have emotes no joke
we have one I don't know I cannot I
don't have more of course mmm
so 97 Queen takes Queen is six King D 8
and then I don't know what should you do
I don't know the the gallant books are
very good yes very recommended
especially the position of this is
position or decision-making book I like
a lot the tactical one is also Cape but
I use them as a strategic
decision-making position all right ok
yeah this is looking pretty awful
I came so I can take him
wait things on the game fort
prefect 0 a TTL you cannot do it yeah
you cannot use the head slap you're not
a subscriber okay so I actually forgot
to trade open d5 forgot to play the
French exchange
this is sort of theory I believe
something like that at least a theory
maybe not the precise position
yeah I don't know I looked at this the
French exchange and I know it has a
boring reputation but I'm completely
fine with playing this and doing all the
time when it looks boring most French
players hated you know
I always like it when they tell me and
French exchange mm-hmm yeah but most
French players they want a close game
and shuffle around the pieces endlessly
and you don't get that damn okay my
simple plan is to take here and take him
yes this is this is indeed in the mix
yeah but I wondered yeah if you would
actually find it and he did
I came so
[Music]
not good nice got to check here and
[Music]
okay so 25 there should be two
not so easy for black actually when you
have a tickle in height there's Quincy
three check no and I lose and this I
felt wouldn't work I thought this is a
deadly pin did that would look something
don't see it in my Eva repertoire
against them a Sicilian I actually
recommend to play the Rosso demo against
296 we should be 5 check against d6 and
the a la pensée 3 against 2 e 6 maybe I
should have chicken with the root K it's
got a 5 Jesus come on I should focus
them it's good if 5 here and maybe this
silly very silly what I did
aha that sucks
it was taken before with the rook and
blackish is completely busted he's gonna
be 5 and wins his piss bag and black is
much better
crazy crazy what I did just take on d4
with the rook and it's basically over
now play too quickly okay so now what is
black up two pawns Jim okay okay I can't
catch up a little bit at least Oh chief
or we should be too okay I can get
deformed maybe I have some drawing
chances
hmm not sure if that helps I might win
on time yes oh it's five plus two oh my
god
so no time wins
no time win
hmm yeah he's not playing this too
brilliantly I mean
hmm yeah I can take now and actually now
I'm a mature
no I'm materially equal all of a sudden
weird okay it's got this count to play
there and give it a five
probably have to take yeah untouched
that's a tough decision this kind of
decision like where time plays a role
and the position plays a role and the
opponent plays a role I think this is
what you often call is just a gut
instinct decision yeah it's it's really
really difficult to say for example in
time pressure if your opponent is low on
time it's always difficult to save if
you should take long take longer yeah or
if you should if you should play a bit
more quickly I often have a huge time
advantage because I'm a very quick
player in tournament chess and I tend to
when my opponent goes low on time I tend
to actually speed up a lot and simply
yeah play a rapid game with the guy and
usually it does not end well yeah for
the opponent but this is something that
you can strongly disagree with that you
should invest more time so in your in
your case it's a it's it's a gut feeling
call really there is no clear pointers
or there's no clear answer and also you
didn't mention the opponent this is a
really important factor what you think
your opponent might do how good he is
and so on you know somehow I started
with an end game two points down and now
I will be probably three pawns up
shortly
it's almost made
is that made probably not
I have to take into account that justice
with incrementally can easily forget
that like you at one point you not don't
look that closely anymore because you
think you're going to win on time anyway
and then owning son you recognize okay
you're not winning on time yeah thanks
for the game deep human that was very
likely pretty bad for me that's at least
no didn't like it okay
pan fiddle ah here we go
I'm sorry but you have to have to enjoy
this
no it seems like pan filled us actually
knowing the theory here
bye-bye to jean-jacques our alpha nil
how could possible how complicated can
you make a name yeah I mean one one
thing is please one thing it's important
you said it was a very romantic double
Bishop sacrifice and so on I mean one
thing is it's also important how
important is that game yeah I mean if
the game is not of utmost sporting
importance and you feel it is simply
interesting go for it of course if you
really feel this is an interesting
continuation I think you should um you
should play it I think okay and you know
he defended us very well
[Music]
hmm yeah it's just equal I don't have
anything I wonder what I did wrong there
because that line is still a little bit
better for white a little bit but
definitely not the way I played it
yeah the accelerators dragon and the
regular dragon if you can call it like
that the regular dragon are really
entirely different so if you say you're
not a dragon player the accelerated
dragon is serve again a completely
different animal
okay rookie age
[Music]
right itself that's very cheeky em but
I'll do it I don't see why not st. the
point is the point is upon ya by two
Lord Kinbote 9a9 falling off your chair
is not healthy go to bed which I will do
probably in roughly 20 minutes 95 of
going down he did not need to give me a
7
no that's it it was a pretty I was
actually pretty important porn
simply because if you can put it onto a
six it controls in porn be 5 square and
now I'm always on the bishop it's
definitely a bit better for me more
pieces feel coordinated
yeah in your situation there untouched
it's of course an important factor then
it was a team event now because yeah you
have to always take into account that
you're not just playing on your own but
if you feel that the team a match
situation was already decided why not go
for something go for something
interesting
yeah the corner my Korean when the
opponent plays a maraca setup is not
that they bore you to death problem is
that it's just good for white off
and black is falling a part of winning
huge chunks of material yeah thanks for
the game hand fiddle so Erin Fisk
no hurry Fisk is a religious patron good
good thing to do
yeah with the challenges I mean I'm
going to stop the stream in roughly 15
minutes so I'm going to go for one more
game maybe two and then call it a name
I'm on for close to three hours already
oh six okay not a very typical pert
smooth oh I will probably just develop
yeah thanks for the good of order of the
best wishes from my team event on Sunday
still have to prepare
yeah next weekend my my team in Germany
we will never mention a third leak okay
so Quinn g3 I tried to get a five and at
some point I wonder probably night
before is an option for black I did not
want to play a lame move like a three so
i habit he goes for it it's probably a
good choice
[Music]
we still have chances to promote and
leak but we also still have chances to
to being relegated and no probably had
something better than a three but I
wanted I want to clear this situation
they're not eating yet the weird
situation in the seat that I'm playing
that my team is playing in is that that
it's a it's a leak with with ten teams
and there are three teams get relegated
to to the league below three is a lot
and it can be it can be pretty tough you
can get relegated even with an even
score like nine nine and it happened
like a team winning the same amount of
matches then losing and so having to go
down
three are no there are three three teams
out of out of ten but there was a real
situation that was we had two teams that
lost every single match and it it worked
out it turned out that with an even
score you could actually yeah get
relegated this won't happen this time
but it's get can be tricky yeah
untouched I haven't played against over
Drogo nope
one of my students did and one actually
that was very nice yeah so what about
this queen is this queen in trouble I
think it is queen age five queen h5g for
route g6
that's crazy yeah I have f5 I believe
wasn't f5 just a fork ah yes you're
right yeah yeah absolutely yeah that
wasn't fine sorry yep
yeah thanks for the game
I earned Fiske so good wheeze I'm going
to play this game and one after that and
then call it a day big promos guys
the people of Knight f6 actually funny
funny
okay back to g8 you can play like that
after this dream it's time for medical
detectives why why hey anything wrong
there
I'll give Fisk could be pronounced
physics
yeah maybe okay so I have to check here
right what happens here
okay I'll just take the extra piece for
nothing
okay yeah this is also quite good
threatening to take here and take on d7
next it's actually difficult to stop
Ruki a tense 95 doesn't look great and
have a piece up already okay
[Music]
miron carrot aureus for screwing up
winning positions but I think I'll
manage this blacks position is not
improving okay thanks for the game cool
breeze so late volley three plus seven
that's a weird time control can you do
that a little bit quicker in three plus
seven that's really weird no I mean I
know you you waited for a long time just
challenge me again just challenge me
again out I'll take that just something
a bit quicker
P P P P RTSs has a question as an I am
what do you still do to actually improve
five plus three that's also long okay I
look like quickly I mean I don't do much
to be honest because I simply don't have
much time for my own chess and I
sometimes actually like by doing lessons
for other people for my students I
actually do improve I think in some way
also through those because I look at
chess positions all the time and I see
new things all the time so this helps a
little bit but I don't really have a
training program I also don't have a
teacher I couldn't I could take one I
have a very straightforward plan Queen
h5f for Bishop age 394 playful maid
let's try
but every every play and regardless of
of overall playing strengths has
strengths and weaknesses ever had
unlimited time with this looks tricky
now I would focus on calculation and end
game playing this is where I could
improve the most especially endings that
are concrete more about calculation than
general principles but this takes time
it really takes time yeah there was a
double attack already was made on h2 and
ds3 hanging so white is in trouble
yeah going going for gold whoo in 92 I
could have taken the rook I know but
there is no good way to say that you
gave to is also not helping wide all
that much
so I'll just take this
fatigues with the pawn actually g4 is
interesting for g3
heretics to the pond G 443 looks more or
less decisive
when do they play the final afraid final
games in their chests and sixty match
tomorrow right so right at this time
when the helium super Blood says if you
actually have to decide what you do
watch magnets or watch the Uni super
blitz fun might have three interesting
you can take him
can go for this intermediate chick Queen
d7 Luke f7
yeah they stylish five right so a little
bit one hour the Florida the yearly
blood starts yeah was we idea that he
was getting flack there I think what the
well first of all I don't understand it
all why they play non increment this
this feels completely stupid
but but also strange that is getting
flag down you can basically I think you
can claim a draw there if you like I
would for Bishop c6 I wasn't a pre move
I just painted it
yeah I guess
yeah I do understand I mean if Carlton
said that he summer was so much like
focused on the actual game that he did
not that he forgot to claim the draw or
something I can't really happen
sometimes
something weird okay
my king position I have to just watch
out a little bit deaf but White has very
little active pieces
that's true and no increment makes TV
schedule easy and I never thought about
that but that's definitely true and they
have their own Norwegian TV yeah maybe
that's actually the reason why they
don't have increment TVs TV schedule
okay thanks for the game late volley
okay we had 2 a.m. here in Germany I'm
on for 3 hours and I need some sleep
absolutely okay make sure to join me
tomorrow I'll start my 5 hour stream I
think it probably will be five hours
let's see what what happens for the
yearly if for the yearly blitz this is
let's have a look the yearly super blitz
we have that coming up tomorrow 6 p.m.
central you Patong so make sure to be on
I haven't also scheduled on Twitch so if
you follow on Twitch or you look at my
twitch starting page you will see that I
have an event scheduled for that so I
hope I'll see you all tomorrow and it
will probably be some good just some
good fun and more than one streamer so
you have some choice who you're going to
follow yeah thanks a lot to all of you
and bye bye until tomorrow